Schweden ist vorreiter beim erreichen der klimaziele ein land dass eines seiner für
2030 gesteckten klimaziele
höchstwahrscheinlich schon im kommenden jahr schaffen wird wow
wie dieser erfolg zu erklären ist was sich andere länder von schweden abgucken können und wie deutschland im ranking
abschneidet das alles und noch viel mehr erfahren sie jetzt bei klicks und seinen wünschen bei uns gibt's täglich science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
Der meeresspiegel steigt an die antarktis
schmilzt es gibt immer mehr dürren und auch hier bei uns werden die wetterphänomene immer extremer wenn wir nichts ändern
wird die temperatur in der antarktis bis im jahr
2070 um krasse drei grad ansteigen und das hätte katastrophale folgen für uns alle doch wir haben es in der hand
wenn wir uns nämlich mal zusammenreißen würden und uns an klima und umweltschutz regeln halten würden sie das szenario
für die zukunft schon viel rosiger aus dann nämlich würde die temperatur
deutlich geringer ansteigen um genau das zu erreichen haben viele länder
klimaschutzziele vereinbart die eu beispielsweise hat sich bis zum jahr 2030 drei hauptziele auf die fahne geschrieben
demnach sollen im vergleich zum jahr 1990 die treibhausgasemissionen um mindestens 40 prozent
reduziert werden
dagegen sollen der anteil der erneuerbaren
energiequellen und auch die energieeffizienz jeweils um 27 prozent erhöht werden das hatten die eu-regierungschefs
im oktober 2014 vereinbart in diesem zusammenhang hat schweden jetzt eine sehr erfreuliche nachricht
verkündet das energieministerium will schon bis zum jahresende rund
terawattstunden an erneuerbaren energien produzieren diese masse bei ursprünglich mal als ein ziel für das jahr
2030 vorgesehen die soll mit knapp
3700 neuen windturbinen passieren die jährlich knapp 20 terawattstunden energie
produzieren könnten bis 2040 dann will das skandinavische land es schaffen seinen kompletten strom aus
erneuerbaren energien zu erzeugen dazu die schwedische klima ministerin
isabella levin in einem interview wenn man sich einmal einen ruck gibt und einfach loslegt geht alles ganz schnell
dazu muss man sagen dass es für schweden aufgrund seiner geografie relativ 1 ach ist energie
aus wind und wasserkraft zu erzeugen dennoch ein super erfolg der echt zu würdigen ist dazu kommt dass die schweden innerhalb der eu für
ehrgeizigere klimaschutzziele
einsetzt und so liegt das skandinavische land in dem ranking der europäischen nichtregierungsorganisationen
kein auf platz eins und zwar mit
77 prozent der von canon geforderten maßnahmen bei der can bewertung ging es darum inwieweit die länder bezüglich des ausbaus der erneuerbaren
energien sind und wie sich die pro-kopf-emissionen
entwickelt haben in das ranking floss auch mit ein wie sich die länder auf eu ebene für strengere klimaziele
einsetzen ja und auf der rangliste hinter schweden folgen portugal frankreich
die niederlande und luxemburg erst auf platz sieben kommt dann deutschland kurz vor litauen und kroatien
beispielsweise weit abgehängt also und tatsächlich schon im klimaschutzbericht von 2017 hatte das umweltministerium
zugegeben seine ziele für 2020 nicht zu erreichen bis dahin werde man beispielsweise den ausstoß von treibhausgasen
nur um rund 30 prozent reduzieren können eigentlich bei einer reduktion um 40
prozent angepeilt das ist nicht einmal 35 prozent werden war eine riesige enttäuschung doch der bericht liefert auch die gründe dafür
oder sommer lieber
ausreden sagen zum einen habe das bevölkerungswachstum unerwartet deutlich zugenommen das liege an den vielen
schutzsuchenden die aus anderen ländern geflohen sind und seit
2015 in deutschland leben und so auch mehr energie verbraucht wird zum anderen habe es eine unerwartete dynamische korrektur entwicklung gegeben einen
wirtschaftsboom also unter anderem liege das wiederum an niedrigen preisen für gas kohle und öl und das bedeutet dann eben auch mehr
produktion verkehr und am langen ende auch mehr schadstoffe laut der organisation für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und entwicklung oecd
sei es gerade in der aktuellen situation
eine umso dringender aufgabe der deutschen politik intensiv und hart gegen die schlechte klimabilanz des landes vorzugehen
die oecd bezieht sich dabei beispielsweise auf den kohle-ausstieg hier ist deutschland in der rolle des größten braunkohle
förderers weltweit ein möglicher lösungsansatz wäre ein co2
dieses preis umweltschützer fordern fordern diesen schon seit längerer zeit dazu der klimachef der umweltstiftung wwf
michael schäfer ein gemeinsamer co2 mindestpreis für den stromsektor hat nicht nur das potenzial
die europäische energiewende voranzutreiben sondern würde deutschland ermöglichen sein
2020 ziel zu erfüllen andere länder sind da schon deutlich weiter in frankreich gibt es seit
2014 einen jährlichen anstieg der co2 steuer für emissionen umweltschützer sind der meinung dass der staat hier frühzeitig den
wirtschaftlichen rahmen setzen muss damit unternehmen nicht so lange auf veraltete technologien setzen wird es deutschland doch noch schaffen
das ist nämlich möglich wie eine studie des fraunhofer instituts belegt hier im video
berichten wir über diese studie einfach draufklicken und darunter kommt jetzt zu unserem whatsapp newsletter nur da bekommt er täglich
vorab den link zum video und zur begrüßung ein kleines geschenk einfach draufklicken und ansonsten abonnieren nicht vergessen bis dann
bleibt dran und die glocke